ننتقل الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
باندلاع اشتباكات هي الاعنف بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في محيط القصر الرئاسي
بالخرطوم وقد استخدمت في المعارك او
استخدمت في المعارك المتجدده اسلحه ثقيله
ومتوسطه وشنه طيران الجيش غارات كثيفه على
اهداف شمالي الخرطوم بحي تصدت لها
المضادات الجويه لقوات الدعم السريع وقال
الجيش السوداني ان قواته اشتبكت فجر اليوم
مع من سماهم المتمردين بعد محاولاتهم
الهجوم على قياده منطقه بحر العسكريه
اذا استطاع التشتيت قواتهم كما ذكرنا
وتدمير عدد من المركبات العسكريه في
المقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع انها
تعرضت الى قصف عشوائي بالمدافع والطائرات
وانها تصدت لهجوم من قوات الاحتياطي
المركزي في وسط الخرطوم والصور التي نشاهد
الان صور مقربه من هذه المواقع التي تشهد
قصفا بين الطيران الحربي للجيش السوداني
في استهدافه لقوات الدعم السريع في مواقع
مختلفه في محيط القصر الرئاسي في الخرطوم
بحري واهداف اخرى كما ذكرنا شمالي الخرطوم
بحري معنا الان
من الخرطوم العاصمه عبر الهاتف مراسلنا
هيثم تمكنت من الوصول الى مكان اكثر امنا
بعد تعرض
محيط مكتب الجزيره او المكان القريب من
مكتب الجزيره
لقصف ايضا وهذه العمليات مستمره ايضا ما
الذي جرى
الاشتباكات ما تظل متواصله كانت حتى قبل
قليل ولكن الان هدات
قوات الجيش
اكثر
محيط القصر الرئاسي كان هناك مناوشات
الخرطوم بحري في منطقه سلاح الاشاره
السريع بشان ما جرى الجيش اكد في بيانه ان
هناك القوات المشتركه منفجر اليوم مع مع
القوه المتمرده حاولت الهجوم على قياده
منطقه بحري العسكريه وبحسب بيان الجيش
انهم كبدوا هذه القوات خسائر فادحه وفي
العتاد وانهم يعني يقومون بمحاوله
ابعادها عن هذه المناطق وتمت التحرير بحسب
بيان وطلب الابتعاد عن المواقع الاشتباكات
وعدم التعامل مع اي اجسام غريبه حصه
سلامتهم حتى وصول الفرق الاجنبيه خاصه
البيان اما بيان القوات الدعم السريع
فقالت انها تدين
التصرفاتها بالتصرفات غير المسؤوله مما
قالت ما اثبتها قوات الانقلابيه وخلونا
نظام باختراقها للهدنه المعلنه ومهاجمه
قواتها في اكثر من موقع اليوم وقالت انها
تصدت لهذه
المحاولات هل هناك طبعا رؤيتان روايتان
مختلفتان حول هذه المعارك الدائره لكل
الطرف لكن الثابته الهدنه يعني التي تم
الاعلان عنها
صراحتها منظمه
هذه المساله والتي تضم جنوب السودان
خلال هذه المده ايضا طلبه الوساطه ان يتم
تسميه ممثل بكل طرف للمواطن لي التفاوض
حول هذه
ما قامت به ما قالت ملتزمون بهذه الوساطه
وانهم سيقومون بهذه الخطوه لكن حتى الان
من الجانب الاخر قوات الدعم السريع لم ترد
على هذه الوساطه رغم ان هناك كانت اتصالات
جرت بين بحسب الدعم السريع بين المبعوث
الاممي الخاص بشؤون الانسان للسودان كل من
قاعده الجيش الشعب الفتاح البرهان
والقياده الدعم السريع بشان الاوضاع
الانسانيه